le terme de démocratie que vous employez
à tout bout de champ et totalement
galvaudé il y à une contradiction
absolue dans les termes et
fondamentalement entre ce qu'est la
démocratie vous avez cité athènes et ce
qu'est le système de la représentation
le système de la représentation n'est
pas du tout la démocratie c'est un
système d'oligarchie élective
alors moi je connais bien le système de
la représentation parce que j'y
travaille
je ne sais pas si pierre henry a essayé
de se présenter à des élections
et ben non qui en rit tout le monde ne
peut pas le faire
et puis même si vous pouvez vous
présenter tout le monde ne peut pas
gagner c'est très compliqué et pourquoi
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il faut
maîtriser un certain nombre de codes un
certain nombre de réseaux avoir un
certain nombre de moyens tout ça est en
forme at et non pas par l'offre
politique mais par le système et ce
système vous pouvez en faire quelque
chose de très différent alors je parle
pas de démocratie participative
forcément de même quelque chose qui
permette véritablement au moins ça
serait déjà un progrès aux 600 mille
élus que vous citez d'avoir un
quelconque droit de regard sur les
décisions qui sont prises
cette émission là elle est consacrée aux
municipales et des roues municipal si je
suis là dit il ya trois quatre personnes
5 6 qui sont à la tête des villes qui
prennent des décisions et tous les
autres tous les élus sont là derrière
pour pour la claque a plaidé hier pour
entériner des décisions ça s'appelle un
vernis et un dimanche foutage de gueule
dans ces conditions s'abstenir c'est au
minimum exprimé que on a les yeux
ouverts et qu'on voit bien tout ça
[Musique]